PROFESSOR: All right, we've been
slogging our way through
derivation of the
plane groups.
And I think I'll do a few more,
because we'll stumble
across some major tricks in
deriving a subfamily of them.
But to not get lost in the
forest because of all the
trees, I have a set of notes.
They are handwritten because my
secretary would resign if
she had to fit in all these
figures and subscripts and
strange symbols.
So, they are as neat as
I could make them.
Sorry to say that, in running
them through the Xerox machine
in an attempt to get everything
on one sheet, some
of the last lines got clipped.
So I'll run these through again
and give you a copy
that's minus those
truncations.
All right.
What we've been doing so far,
to have a brief reprise, was
to take the symmetries, the 10
two-dimensional plane group
symmetries.
And they were one-, two-,
three-, four-, or sixfold
axes, a mirror plane,
2mm, 3m, 4mm, 6mm.
So there are 10 of them.
And these are the so-called
crystallographic point groups.
Crystallographic because we
considered only those rotation
axes that are compatible
with a lattice.
And they are point groups
because they leave at least
one point in space,
invariant--
stays there rigidly fixed.
And they are groups because the
collection of operations
that are present satisfies the
postulates of the mathematical
entity called a group.
We've then are in the process of
taking these 10 symmetries
and adding them to the 5
two-dimensional lattices.
The parallelogram net, the
rectangular, the centered
rectangular, and the square,
and the hexagonal.
And clearly, we can't put each
of those point groups in every
one of the lattices.
For example, the lattice has to
be square for either 4 or
4mm, so we would attempt to
place only those two of the 10
point groups into
a square net.
We've gone through quite
a few of them.
I won't bother to draw
the pattern of
the symmetry elements.
But we put no symmetry
at all in the general
parallelogram net.
And that is plane group P1.
Maybe I will draw the
figures, after all.
P2 was a twofold axis dropped
into a net, which had to have
no specialized shape, simply
because a twofold [INAUDIBLE]
axis requires nothing but a
lattice row if one translation
is combined with it.
The threefold axis could fit
into an equilateral net.
And there's the threefold axis
we added to a lattice point.
And we have two additional
threefold axes in the centers
of those 2 equilateral
triangles, which each make up
half the cell.
P4 was the square net.
We put a fourfold axis at
the corner of the cell.
We've got another one
in the middle.
Two folds in the middle of
the edges because of the
180-degree rotation that is
built into the fourfold axis.
And P6.
We put that into a
hexagonal net.
We've got sixfold axes that we
dropped in at the lattice
point only, nothing else.
There's a 120-degree rotation at
the lattice point, and that
gives us the threefold
axes that are
present in P3, as well.
There's a 180-degree rotation
contained in a sixfold axis,
and that gives us the twofold
axes in all of the
locations of P2.
OK, I haven't drawn in any
representative patterns, but
let me remind you again.
The pattern that is
characteristic of every one of
the plane groups is just the
pattern that the point group
that you've placed at the
lattice point would produce.
And that pattern is, in turn,
hung at every lattice point of
the two-dimensional cell.
So even though the huge number
of symmetry elements that's
present in the higher symmetry
point groups is rather
intimidating--
you say, wow, how would one
draw a pattern for that--
the pattern is nothing more
complicated than the pattern
of the symmetry that you've
placed at the lattice point.
And all of these other symmetry
elements arise to
express relations between the
motifs that you've placed at
the initial representative
lattice point.
Deriving these, we used one
theorem, which it's well to
remind you of.
And that is that if I have a
rotation operation A alpha,
follow that by a translation
that's perpendicular to the
rotation axis, what I get
is a new rotation
operation is B alpha.
And it's located in a very
specific location.
And that is at a location that's
a distance x equal half
the magnitude of the translation
times the
cotangent of alpha over 2.
So this combination term, if
nothing else, reminds us that
these combination theorems, as I
call them, are not equations
in symmetry elements.
They are equations in individual
operations.
So, for example, if I combine
the fourfold axis with the
translation, the 180-degree
operation that's present in a
fourfold axis puts B pi here.
The 90-degree rotation puts
B pi over 2 here.
And the 270-degree rotation--
which I can define just as well
as A minus pi over 2--
puts the operation A minus
2 pi over 2 down here.
So it's not an equation
in symmetry elements.
It's an equation in individual
operations.
Then some peculiarities started
to arise, which we
perhaps might not think of.
If we put a mirror plane in a
primitive rectangular net,
that gave a group that
we called Pm.
If we combine that with a
translation, we need a theorem
that says what happens if you
combine a mirror reflection
operation with a translation
that's perpendicular to it.
We sketch that out, and once and
for all could decide that
it's going to be a new
reflection operation that's
located halfway along this
perpendicular translation.
So this reflection operation
sigma, combined with this
translation, gave us a new
reflection operation, sigma
prime, halfway along the cell.
And, of course, we have
this one hanging at a
lattice point as well.
And then came the
interesting one.
When we combined a mirror plane
now with the centered
rectangular net, we have all of
the mirror planes that we
have here, because this
primitive rectangular lattice
is a subgroup of the
centered lattice.
Then the interesting thing
happened when we combined the
reflection operation sigma with
this translation that
went to the center
of the cell.
And that gave us a
transformation that was
something we had not
encountered before.
We took an object, reflected
it in this plane, and then
translated it down
to a centered
lattice point over here--
to give us one that sat here--
and then asked, how did I get
from the first one, a
right-handed one perhaps,
to a second one that's a
left-handed one, and then a
third left-handed one that
sits down here?
The answer is that we found
there was no way we could
specify getting from number 1 to
number 3 in a single shot.
We had to take two
steps to do it.
And there was nothing more
simple than that.
We had to first translate
down by the part of the
translation--
let me call it tau--
which is equal to that part of
the translation t, which is
parallel to the reflection
operation.
And then we had to reflect
across, and that would get us
from the first to the third.
That was a new sort
of operation.
We'd indicate its locus by a
dashed line to distinguish it
from a mirror plane.
And it has a translation part
and a reflection part.
Doesn't matter what order
in which we do them.
We get to the same location if
we reflect first and then
slide or slide first
and then reflect.
So this was a new operation
that I'll
represent by sigma tau--
looks sort of like a symbol
for reflection, but the
subscript reminds us you've got
to translate by an amount
tau that is parallel to the
initial mirror plane.
And this gave us a new theorem
that a general translation
that had a part t perpendicular
and a component
t parallel, when it followed
a reflection operation, was
equal to a net effect of
reproducing the object by a
glide plane, sigma tau prime.
It had tau equal to the part
of the translation that was
parallel to the reflection
part of the locus.
And it was located always at
one-half the perpendicular
part of the translation.
So using that theorem and
completing the mirror planes
that hang at the lattice
points, we have a very
interesting group that consists
of a centered
lattice, mirror plane hung at
the corner lattice point--
this is also a lattice point,
so we automatically get the
mirror plane in the middle
of the cell--
and then in between, we get this
new 2-step operation, the
glide plane.
And the pattern that's
representative of this plane
group is, as advertised, just
what a mirror plane does.
And that is hung at every
lattice point of the centered
rectangular net.
So the glide plane, this new
operation that popped up, does
what the new operations
did in all of the
other preceding groups.
It tells you how do you get from
the pair that you've hung
at the lattice point to
these that sit in the
center of the cell.
They're related by translation,
but the relation
of one to another of these
motifs is by the glide plane.
So that is an operation which
has arisen in the group.
And this, then, is a group
that we would call Cm.
C for a centered rectangular
net, as opposed to the
primitive net, which is the one
we got immediately before.
Again, I sound like a cracked
record sometimes, but let me
emphasize the simplicity
of these patterns.
Again, the pattern consists of
what you would get when you
hung a motif on one lattice
point, and then that is
repeated by m, which is the
symmetry you've placed at a
lattice point.
And that's hung at every lattice
point of the centered
rectangular net.
The glide planes just express
relations between things that
you already have when you've
hung the motifs
on the lattice point.
Any questions after this
brief reprieve?
Comments?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You called those
[INAUDIBLE] glides,
that's a sigma tau?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The relation between
this one and this
one, I've called sigma.
That's the reflection
operation.
The relation between this one
and this one down here would
be the operation that has
a reflection part and a
translation part, tau.
Let me point out something
that's worth observing when we
start making some more
complex additions.
We said early on that we only
have to consider translations
that terminate within
the unit cell.
Because everything is
translationally periodic--
not only the atoms in the
motifs but the symmetry
elements as well.
But the observation that I want
to make is that if we put
a glide plane in.
And let's do that for the direct
addition of a glide
plane to a lattice point.
And having done that, we have
the potential of possibly
having derived a group that
we would call Cg.
OK.
This diagonal translation--
this is T1, and this is T2.
We might ask, what is the
reflect [INAUDIBLE] glide
operation that sits at the
origin lattice point, followed
by T1 plus T2.
Well, what does our
theorem tell us?
It says that we should get
a new glide plane.
It should be at one-half of the
perpendicular part of the
translation.
And the perpendicular part
of the translation is T2.
So this is at one-half of T2,
and it should have a glide
component equal to the
parallel part of the
translation, and that is T1.
T1 plus the original glide
component, tau.
What is this?
A glide component of half of
T1 plus the entire T1.
If we ask, does that
make sense?
Yeah, we would glide down to
here and then we would
translate down to here.
And that would give us sitting
at half of a path of T1, a new
object that sat here.
Is that a glide operation?
Yeah, it is.
But it is one that is not really
distinct from the glide
plane that sits here.
Because if we have a glide
operation with tau equal to
one-half of T1, and if this
sits in a lattice, then
there's going to be a glide
plane has tau equal to 1 plus
one-half of T1.
And there will have to be
another glide operation that
consists of 2 plus
one-half of T1.
And the reason is that
everything is periodic at an
interval T1.
So the moral that I'm trying to
draw here is that one can
add or subtract to identify the
actual nature of a symmetry.
One can add or subtract
an integral number of
translations.
And that permits one to reduce
any tau to a sigma tau prime,
such that tau prime is always
less than the translation
that's parallel to the tau.
In other words, lop off this
translation of an entire T1,
this translation of the entire
T2, and you have identified
the basic nature of the glide
operation that sits here as
something with a translation
that's half of T1.
The translations that move
motifs out of the cell may be
related by a glide operation
that involves an integral
number of T1s plus half of T1.
But it doesn't change the basic
nature of the simplest
glide step that's in there.
That's a very obscure
explanation of probably
something that didn't puzzle
you in the first place, but
it's worth saying when we make
some of these additions.
Let's finish this off.
We have another translation
in here, and that's the
translation T1 plus T2 over 2.
So, what would we get if we took
the glide operation sigma
one-half of T1 and followed
that by a translation T1
plus T2 over 2.
And that operation, again,
would be equal to a glide
plane sigma prime with the tau
equal to the original glide
component plus the part of the
translation that is parallel
to the glide plane.
And it'd be located at one-half
of the perpendicular
part of the translation,
which is T2.
So it'd be at one-half
of one-half of T2.
So this says that the
combination of the glide
operation with the centered
translation is a glide plane
with a glide component T1.
And it's located at
one-quarter of T2.
And that, indeed, is what you
would do if you reflected and
reproduced the object by a glide
down to here and then
translated by T2 over to here.
OK.
No, I'm sorry.
We glided and then we added on
the parallel part of the
translation.
So we would end up down here.
And if one sits here,
there has to be one
repeated by T1 up here.
And this is exactly the same
thing as a reflection plane
that's been introduced.
So here is a case where we could
subtract off the entire
translation T1 and say this is
identical to a mirror plane
passing through the origin, a
pure mirror plane sigma that
is at one-quarter of T2.
So, let me clean this up and
show you what we have.
Completing the operations, we
would have a pair of objects
related by glide, like
this, that is hung at
every lattice point.
It's also hung at the centered
lattice point.
And what that is going to give
us is a pair of objects that
sit like this.
And what has come in as a result
of those combinations
is a mirror plane interleaved
between the glide planes.
And this is exactly what we
have in Cm, which was also
interleaved mirror planes and
glide planes with the origin
shifted by one-half
one-quarter of T2.
So this is not in a group.
Proceeding logically, we'd take
Cm and replace the mirror
plane by a glide.
When we do that, we have
a consistent group.
But it turns out to be exactly
the same arrangement of
symmetry elements and exactly
the same pattern as Cm, but
with a little nudge over along
T2 by one-quarter of that
translation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But in Cm, didn't we
have mirror planes going
through the lattice points?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And what I'm saying is here
there are glide planes going
through, but the lattice
point is arbitrary.
I can put it anywhere I like.
And if I decide to put the
lattice point here, that turns
it into Cm.
OK?
So, let's put the two of
them side by side.
Cm was this mirror plane, mirror
plane, mirror plane
glides, and the atoms
motifs did this.
A lattice point here
in the center.
And I'll deliberately, to make
my case, offset the cell by
one-quarter of T1.
Now I've got a glide plane
here, same as this one.
Mirror plane at a
quarter of T1.
Glide plane here at the centered
lattice point.
Mirror plane here, glide
point T2 away.
And here are the
lattice points.
But the pattern of objects
looks like this.
Armed in advance on what the
thing has to look like.
Looks like this.
And this is exactly the same
pattern of motifs.
OK.
So, coming out of this
consideration, we have with
the rectangular nets
Pm, Cm, Pg.
But Cg, if we try to construct
it, was the same as Cm.
And that exhausts the
possibilities for a single
symmetry plane and the
rectangular nets.
OK.
Let me move on then
to the next step.
And I'm going to skip over
a threefold axis.
And I'm going to look at the
square net combined with the
other symmetry that would
require a net with this
dimensionality.
And this would be a primitive
square lattice plus 4 mm.
We've already done almost
all the work.
So as we derive the symmetries
that are subgroups of these
higher symmetries,
we've done P4.
And that says that if we put a
fourfold access at the origin,
that fourfold axis, we'll
get another one in the
center of the cell.
And we'll get twofold axes in
the midpoints of all the edges
of the cell.
And then 4 mm has one kind
of mirror plane.
Two Ms because there are two
kinds of mirror planes.
The mirror plane says, hey, if
I'm in a lattice, I want to be
at right angles to a rectangular
or a centered
rectangular net.
Well, OK.
This one is happy, because a
square net is a special case
of a rectangular net.
The two translations
are merely equal.
So he is happy.
Combine that with T2, and we'll
get another mirror plane
like this, and another mirror
plane like this.
Fourfold axis is going to rotate
that mirror plane, so
we'll have mirror planes
running this way,
and this way as well.
And now we have a different kind
of mirror plane that we
tried to put in in
this location.
This mirror plane says, hey, I
have to be parallel to the
edge of a rectangular net or
a centered rectangular net.
So if we look at the
translations that are parallel
to and perpendicular to this
translation, lo and behold,
this mirror plane is aligned
along the edge of a centered
rectangular net that has the
additional specialization of
being a centered square.
But that mirror plane now
is perfectly happy.
And he says, OK, I'll
hold my piece.
I have the arrangements of
translations relative to my
orientation that
makes me happy.
So I can say now that there
is a mirror plane
running this way.
There has to be another mirror
plane 90 degrees away from
those orientations.
And this, then, is going to be
the location of all the mirror
planes in that net.
And at no time did the chalk
ever leave my fingers.
Just doing what we
said we're doing.
Putting in 4 mm, making sure
the requirements imposed on
the lattice are those that that
symmetry element demands.
And here we go.
Except that there is now one
other combination that we have
not considered.
Here is a mirror plane.
And now this mirror plane
is diagonal to
our translation T2.
And here is a mirror plane.
And that mirror plane
is diagonal to
our translation T1.
So what is that going
to require?
Here is the mirror plane, that's
the operation sigma.
And here is our translation,
T1, down to here.
We have a theorem that says that
a reflection followed by
a translation that has a general
orientation is going
to give me a new reflection
operation, sigma prime, that's
located at one-half the
perpendicular part of the
translation.
And it's going to have a glide
component that is equal to
one-half of the parallel part
of the translation.
So what has that told us?
To get from this mirror plane
down to here, we've gone this
far in a sense that is
perpendicular to the mirror
plane, so this is
T perpendicular.
And we have a part of the
translation that is parallel
to the mirror plane.
This is T parallel.
So the plane that results
is going to be a
glide plane in here.
It's located at one-half of the
perpendicular part of the
translation.
And that is one-half of one-half
of T1 plus T2.
And it has a glide component
equal to T parallel, which is
equal to one-half
of T1 plus T2.
So we get a new glide
plane in here.
And that will require glide
planes through similar
arguments that go down
the diagonals of
the cell, like this.
And let me convince you that
that, in fact, is an operation
that must arise if I place, at
the origin of the cell, a set
of objects that have
4 mm symmetry.
We have one like this, one
like this, one like this.
Another pair hanging here.
And if we do a reflection
operation, let's say this pair
up to this pair, and then slide
it down by the diagonal
translation--
and we have the same set, again,
hanging down here at
the diagonally opposed
lattice point.
Reflect across, slide
down to here.
The way in which you get that
is, believe it or not, to
reflect across this
glide plane.
How do we get there?
We reflect across.
We translate down to here.
And the way I do that is by
reflecting across this
diagonal glide.
That probably has convinced
no one.
But map it out with your
own pattern, and I
think you'll agree.
Let me observe, while you're
considering that.
When we derive groups based on
3m or 6mm, we're going to have
other cases where a translation
along the edge of
the cell is inclined
to a mirror plane.
And the effect of combining a
translation with a mirror
plane that's inclined to that
translation always has the
effect of interposing a glide
plane halfway in between the
mirror planes that are related
by translation.
So, let me say that in general,
because that will be
an observation that'll let us
identify glide planes quickly.
So the general resolve is if we
have a translation inclined
to a mirror plane, which of
necessity is repeated by
translation, a quite general
result is that a glide plane
is interleaved always
between the two.
And they'll be parallel because
they're related by
translation.
So we'll see some more cases
where we can immediately state
that without further thought.
OK.
There is something that we
might consider doing.
I'd like to put it
off, though.
Here we start with
a mirror plane.
Can we replace the mirror plane
with a glide plane?
The answer is yes, we can.
But it's not at all clear if I
take a fourfold axis and put a
glide plane through it, what
this plane has to be.
So I'd like to leave this one
for now and come back to that.
OK.
In the notes, I've tried to do
all of these derivations
thoroughly and logically.
So if this is a bit fast or me
waving my hands, saying a
glide plane is here, and this,
that, and the other thing,
when you can't really see what
I'm pointing at, I think if
you refer to the notes
that'll be clear.
But yes, you had a question?
AUDIENCE: So you said that this
glide plane [INAUDIBLE]
one-half T perpendicular.
What did you write
underneath that?
I guess that maybe is where
your T and one-half T
perpendicular is where
the glide plane is.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I was just demonstrating that,
in fact, for this mirror plane
with the diagonal translation,
the glide plane would come in
at one-half of the perpendicular
part of the
translation.
And the part of the
translation that--
we were combining this fourfold
access with this
translation.
So the perpendicular part of the
translation is half of the
body diagonal.
And if a glide plane comes in
one-half of the perpendicular
part of the translation, that
put it parallel to the mirror
plane and at one-quarter of the
way of the translation.
So this little scrawl here
says it one-half of T
perpendicular and one-half of
one-half of the body diagonal.
So it's one-quarter.
All this equals one-quarter
of T1 plus T2.
OK.
Now something unexpected
happens.
If we would move along,
I skipped over 3m.
We know what P3 looks like.
And that is a hexagonal net,
an equilateral net.
And we have a threefold axis
that we've added to the
lattice point.
And then we found additional
threefold axes in the center
of these triangles.
And, once again, the pattern
that has this symmetry is just
a triangle of objects hung
at every lattice point.
And now we want to add
a mirror plane to
that threefold axis.
So we have a primitive
equilateral net plus the
two-dimensional plane
point group 3m.
The question is, which
way should we
orient the mirror plane?
Well, a mirror plane says, I
want to be along the edge of
either a centered rectangular
net or a
primitive rectangular net.
There's nothing about this
lattice that looks
rectangular.
Yeah, there is.
I see a couple of people
doing this, and they
have the right idea.
Here's a lattice point.
If we go more than one unit cell
in this diagram, here's a
lattice point.
Here's a lattice point.
Go down to here and
go over to here.
And lo and behold, here is a
centered rectangular net,
hiding incognito in
a hexagonal net.
Well, that helps.
I can put in the mirror plane.
But let me point out-- this is
getting very messy, so I'll
redraw it on a smaller scale.
This will be worth doing so that
it's perfectly obvious.
I'm going to draw a number
of equilateral nets.
The reason I'm drawing more than
one cell, I would like to
point out that here is one
centered rectangular net.
And it has its edge
perpendicular to the
translations in the
hexagonal net.
But there is also a rectangular
net that
goes down like this.
That's a centered rectangular
net that has its edge along
one of edges of the unit cell.
So I have two possibilities.
One is to draw the rectangular
net like this.
The other one is to draw the
rectangular net like this.
And having confused you
thoroughly, let me simply draw
this larger cell again.
And say that I could, if I
wanted to, put the mirror
planes in in these directions,
along the edges of the cell.
OK.
And in this case, if you're
convinced that there's a
centered rectangular
net sitting there.
Let me clean this up.
And here's one mirror plane.
60 degrees away is another
mirror plane.
And there'll be another mirror
plane at this lattice point
doing this.
So now I've got 3m at every one
of these threefold axes.
And I got all those simply by
repeating these mirror planes
by translation.
But in one case, the mirror
planes are perpendicular to
the cell edge.
This being T1, let's say,
and this being T2.
In this case, the mirror
planes are along the
edges of the cell.
This being T1, and
this being T2.
So, holy mackerel!
One point group.
Two different space groups,
which differ in the way in
which the symmetry is oriented
relative to the lattice.
And if you think back a little
bit, this particular net, with
this dimensional specialization,
was happy with
a sixfold access as well, and
will be compatible with 6mm.
So, really, these two different
orientations for the
mirror planes, even though we
haven't got there yet, are the
two different orientations
which are both present
simultaneously if we were
to put 6mm into
this hexagonal net.
So, same point group.
Same lattice.
Two different plane groups that
depend on the orientation
of the symmetry relative
to the lattice.
So there isn't even a one-to-one
correspondence
between the point groups
and the plane groups.
The pattern for either of these
is, once again, going to
be just what the pattern of
the point group does.
If we start with a motif here
and repeat that by the
threefold axis and the mirror
planes, we would
have motifs like this.
And here the translation points
out in between the
mirror planes.
In this case, the mirror
planes would repeat the
objects in two locations,
like this.
So, indeed, both patterns
have 3mm symmetry.
And what's different is the way
the translations come out
in between those
mirror planes.
OK.
Now our notation has come
up against an impasse.
We said that the notation for
the plane group should be the
symbol for the lattice type,
which the initiated know has
to be a hexagonal net.
The point group that we've
added, which is 3m, but now
how do we distinguish the two
different orientations of the
mirror planes?
And the way around that is to
actually use three symbols.
And the second symbol
will be what is
perpendicular to the cell edge.
And the third symbol
will be what's
parallel to the cell edge.
So this one would
be called P3M1.
And this one, just to
distinguish it, would be
called P31M.
So if this weren't bad enough,
now you've got almost the same
symbol with a permutation of
two of the terms in it.
In this case, the mirror plane
is along the cell edge along
the translations.
In this case, it's
perpendicular.
But we're not quite yet done,
because we've got translations
that are inclined to
mirror planes.
And now you can see how prudent
I was in saying quite
generally, without trying to
figure out what is the
perpendicular part and what is
the parallel part, here's a
translation and it's at an
angle to a mirror plane.
And therefore we get a glide
that has to be halfway between
these mirror planes.
And there'll have to be a glide
halfway between these
mirror planes, and a glide
that's halfway between these
mirror planes.
In this case, the mirror
planes are this way.
Again, a translation that's
inclined to the mirror plane.
We have to have a glide
that is midway between
these mirror planes.
In this case, they're a little
easier to identify.
They sort of make a triangular
box that surrounds the
threefold axis.
So now we see another difference
in the plane groups
and the reason why they're
so very distinct.
And that is the rearrangement of
the glides relative to the
threefold axes are quite
different in these two cases.
So these are two quite
different symmetries.
Notice that when we start
identifying special locations
in these two plane groups, here
there is a location only
of symmetry 3mm for a point
group, 3m for a point group.
Here there are two different
locations, one that's symmetry
3m, the other one is
just symmetry 3.
So this is location of point
group 3 and a location of
point group 3m.
So the sort of special positions
that exist in these
two plane groups will be
very, very different.
One more addition, and then I
think we can leave with a
light heart because
we should be done.
What about a primitive
hexagonal net
combined with 6mm?
And if you think I'm going
to try to draw
that, you're crazy.
But I can say quite simply and
hopefully convince you that
this looks like P31M plus P3M1
right on top of one another,
because we've got mirror
planes that
are 30 degrees apart.
So, as a schematic direction and
an invitation to do this
at home in your spare time, is
to take what P6 looks like.
And that's sixfold axes
at the lattice points.
Threefolds here.
Twofolds here.
And then, directly on top of
this, place the mirrors and
glides in this orientation, and
the mirrors and glides in
this orientation.
So we will have mirror planes
coming out like that, and
glide planes in between all the
parallel mirror planes.
As I say, I'm heroic
but not foolish.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you just explain
that derivation again?
Your P3 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
The object of this additional
bit of confusion is to put in
the symbol the point group,
which is 3m, and then tell you
how the mirror plane in a
point group is oriented
relative to the edges
of the cell.
And we could call them anything
we wanted to.
We could call them P3M
perpendicular, subscript
perpendicular.
Or P3M subscript parallel to
indicate mirror plane parallel
to the cell edge.
And mirror plane perpendicular
Or we could call them some
obscenity, which would be very
descriptive, as well.
But this is just a way of
keeping track of what's
parallel to the cell
edge and what's
perpendicular to the cell edge.
So, this middle symbol is what's
oriented perpendicular
to the cell edge.
And in this case, this is the
mirror plane and that is
perpendicular.
All the mirror planes are
perpendicular to the
edges of the cell.
And then parallel to the
cell edge, there's
no symmetry at all.
So that's 1.
1 stands for no symmetry.
In this case, the mirror plane
is along the cell edge, so
there's an M in the
third position.
And perpendicular to the
cell edge, there's
no symmetry at all--
no symmetry plane at all.
So it's purely arbitrary, but
we need some mechanism for
distinguishing which one
we're talking about.
That pretty much works
as well as anything.
And it's a minor perturbation
of what we've done for the
additional plane
group symbols.
All right.
It's time for our midafternoon
break.
It's a nice place to quit,
because you're probably
feeling good.
We've done this, and we can
move on to something new.
Actually, there's
one more trick.
And unless you were really
clever, you wouldn't have
thought of it.
But there's another small family
of plane groups that we
can get through one
particular device.
I shouldn't have told you that,
because you'll be less
inclined to come back now.
But we're almost through.
And I think it'll be very clear
what these additional
possibilities are.